METE ATAMEL:
Translation API can be
used to dynamically
translate a string
into any supported language.
Let's see how to use
Translation API with C#.
First, make sure the API
is enabled in your project
and the service account
exist to make API calls.
Both are explained in the
code lab in the video notes.
In Cloud Shell, let's create
a simple .NET console app.
And add Translation API
NuGet package to the project.
Open the online code editor
and navigate to program.cs.
We will translate an
English text to Turkish.
Reference to the
Translation API library.
Create translation client.
Specify the text to
translate, and call
Translate Text on the text
with to and from languages.
Finally, print the translation.
Let's run the app.
There you go.
You just translated text
using Translation API.